ladies and gentlemen i'm here to respond
to steph and georgie who said that my
video confession of a copywriter was
unfair to the industry and falsely
painted them in a bad light
hey it's just a few bad apples in direct
response
most of them are doing it ethically so
i'm making this response in return
called delusions of a copywriter now
stefan has a special reason uh for
wanting to defend his profession number
one
he sold 700 million dollars worth of
product so okay it's what he does that's
fine
but also he's engaged in some of the
terrible
practices that i describe in my video
but i wanted to say
because i think i'll probably offend a
few people in this video
right up top i think most direct
response copywriting that is going on
right now in this industry is ethically
indefensible
and i also wanted to throw down the
gauntlet look if you disagree with that
statement
come on the show i'm happy to give you a
platform if you think any of this
that's in stefan george's little post
here is defensible
please come on the show because i think
it'd be a great conversation to have
because so far you know you just post in
this facebook group where everyone
agrees with you what are we gonna do
right now notice i did not say
that all copywriting is ethically
indefensible or all direct response
copywriting is ethically
indefensible because i don't think it is
i think there are ethical copywriters
definitely out there
which makes the first thing this guy
says that the main premise of my video
is direct response copywriting is scammy
and responsible for ripping people off
false and maybe that's because he only
watched the first 20 minutes or so
but uh yeah that's wrong the main
premise is actually
that the majority of direct response
copywriting is scammy and responsible
for ripping people off
there's ethical copywriting obviously
there's ethical copywriting obviously
a small difference but an important
distinction because i'm not
painting his whole point is that i paint
the whole industry with one brush
no i just happen to be talking about the
most predatory side of the industry but
i'm not painting the whole industry with
one brush but anyways
let's uh talk about what he says okay
i'm gonna have to summarize it but
if you want to read the whole post i
will leave it in the description
so basically he says look direct
response copywriting
normal advertising coca-cola hey agora
coca-cola
swiffer newmarket health what's really
the difference
right now he does concede that some of
the claims in copywriting are a little
ridiculous
but he says look when it comes to the
product things like this it's about the
same right
some things work some things kind of
work and some things just are pixie dust
he calls it right and he concludes it
with uh this example
look he says swiffer sweeper they kind
of lie to you
in their ad they make it look so easy to
pick up dust
and spills and does it really work that
well so he says look it goes into the
mixed results back
but does that mean that swiffer is
preying on the weak or that
their scammy company that should be
banned from advertising on tv
seems hard to make that leap in my mind
so he equates
what he does to the swiffer sweeper now
let's dig into what he does because
notice he didn't bring up any of the
products
in direct response and i think that was
smart of him because if he had it would
have started look to look pretty
ridiculous because let's talk about
one of the products stefan georgie has
sold and i apologize for not using a
more recent one but honestly it's hard
to find out what these people
have written about because their names
aren't on anything you kind of have to
hunt down
what they're actually attached to so he
definitely wrote this this is something
called
memory healer okay now ask yourself
do you think this is about the same
level of predatory as swiffer sweeper
the evil broom company do you think this
is slightly more predatory do you think
this is
definitely more predatory what do you
think maybe swiffer sweeper is more
predatory
okay hi my name is alexander lynch
and the incredible story you're about to
hear
hundred percent true actually first
let's start with some irony
the story is a hundred percent false
about three and a half years ago
my father pointed a shotgun to my face
and pulled the trigger he didn't do it
because he was a psycho or because there
was some sort of a family feud
it happened because when i
unintentionally startled him
his early stage two alzheimer's which at
that time hadn't been diagnosed
caused him to become panicked and
confused running to the closet
he pulled out his 12 gauge and fired it
right at my head
he simply believed he was protecting his
home and didn't realize that he almost
murdered his only son
it was too much disturbing and
horrifying experiences for both of us
something that still gives me nightmares
to this day
and it's also what sent me on a comp by
the way i know that this seems like
ridiculous like who would fall for this
but who is this product targeted towards
it's about alzheimer's right
it's targeted towards seniors so they're
actually trying to scare
seniors or maybe the seniors uh son or
daughter
so look so what they're taking advantage
of seniors isn't that the same as
selling a swiffer sweeper greatly
unexpected
two-year-long journey through the dark
underbelly of the multi-billion dollar
corporate medicine universe
a journey that opened my eyes to the
sick predatory
and ultimately deadly practices of the
pharmaceutical conglomerates
and that would eventually lead to the
discovery of a completely natural
100 percent effective way that could
reverse even the most severe cases of
alzheimer's
dementia uh oops hey
this is not the swiffer sweeper you're
trying to scare
seniors into selling them a 100
effective way that could reverse the
most severe cases of
alzheimer's and dementia which by the
way
incurable diseases no matter whether the
one suffering was in the very late stage
i don't even want to put you guys
through this they're targeting
people who are in their last
stage of life and trying to milk them
for
all the money they're worth now
that is what i would call something that
is preying on the weak
or a scammy company that should be
banned
that is what i'm talking about and with
that i want to talk about
what makes a predatory advertiser
because stefan doesn't seem to
understand
what makes a company predatory it's
pretty simple what
makes all the difference in the world is
pushing your product onto desperate
people who have no choice but
to buy it and overcharging them for it
while you're at it so
this happens primarily in two industries
two industries
by the way which direct response
copywriters love
health and wealth okay now
why do these attract desperate people
well because let's take the example of
uh
health let's take the extreme case say
you're offering a cancer drug
right someone's been told that by their
doctors hey
you're honestly we we have nothing left
for you that's usually when people go to
these direct response copywriters
they're looking for a
a salvation right they're looking for a
miracle pill
these are desperate people that will pay
any price
and you appeal to them with products
like the one we just saw
like this memory healer right here you
take their money
and they have no recourse but to buy it
right because you have to try it you're
going to try it either way even though
it might look scummy you might not trust
the person you're gonna buy it
the same is true with wealth products if
you tell me i'm gonna get rich
and i work at mcdonald's a nine-to-five
job making minimum wage
right i'm gonna buy your product which
in of itself
isn't the end of the world but as you
and i both know
most of these products simply do not
work or if they do work
they work for one percent maybe half a
percent of people
not the 100 success rate that is usually
promised in the copy
that's what makes it predatory because
you're preying on the lowest
level the lowest denominator of society
to try to take their money
and that's who a lot of these people are
targeting it's not people
who are well to do engineers right who
have their life together
it is desperate people either a
desperate mom
who needs to lose weight and you're
selling them some some solution you know
is not going to work
or they're some old person you're
selling them health cures that you know
is not going to work
or they're young and you're selling them
some get rich biz
op right these are the classics of
direct response it's the foundation
on which a lot of this industry is built
now with that said with uh
the this obvious point debunked here
i want to go on because one of his
biggest things that i take
issue with is that look he says to bait
the whole industry of cd and crappy
first of all i didn't paint the whole
industry i just painted most of the
industry
uh as crappy because of some bad actors
doesn't seem fair
because when you look at the biggest
players most of whom i've written for
what you find is they don't use
sensational stories
they're incessantly focused on making
sure their claims are legit
and they really genuinely care about
their products
uh are you
nuts this is exactly
the point i'd make but in reverse look i
actually
agree with stefan that if you want to
evaluate an industry
you don't look at the worst you look at
the best of the industry right
the top of the industry so when you look
at the top of the advertising industry
who might you find you might find
i don't know apple they're selling a
real product right
you might find amazon's you might find
the verizon wirelesses
you might find coca-cola these people
look
you can argue that coca-cola is not
going to bring you happiness so that's
like a little deceptive
but they're not appealing to people who
are on their last leg okay
now let's move away from that and talk
about direct response if you look at the
best in the direct response game
who do you talk about well the obvious
case is
agora right they're the biggest company
in direct response and
actually all steph and georgie should
know because one of the companies they
talk about training
is agora financial so this must be then
one of the companies that uh
stefan really stands by they don't use
sensational stories
they're insistently focused on making
sure their claims are legit
they really genuinely care about their
products oh do they
hey why don't we talk about that this is
something called
a deep dive into the heart and mind of
the financial publication buyer
this is done by the in-house copywriter
at agora financial
and he's about to talk to salesmen who
talk to their customers and we're about
to find out
what they really believe they say about
their own customers
they really are looking for the magic
pill that would be my distillation of
about
10 years they're talking about their
customers they're looking for the
financial
magic pill now let me go out on a limb
here and say that
they're attracting customers who are
looking for a magic pill
because they're selling magic pills and
you might say well that's just my
opinion
but consider how weird it would be if a
car salesman
said that people were coming looking for
anything other than cars
you attract people based on what you're
selling so it stands to reason that if
the distillation of 10 years of selling
is that people come to your company
looking for magic pills
well what do you think you're selling
and it's not me saying that that's their
own copywriter and salesmen who admit
that
they say about their customers it's a
lot of people who are panicked
back against the wall trying to make up
for lost time sound like desperation to
you
these people at the top of the direct
response industry agora financial
who stefan says oh yeah right what did
he say
oh they don't use sensational stories
here they are
in their own words talking about using
sensational stories
yeah well the retire a millionaire i
don't know what it was
30-day retirement blueprint yeah that
one
that was hell on the phone people like
here's a good example of the power
like you get it the power of copy right
but when that promo first launched i
remember specifically and this was god
probably six years ago i talked to
people
out of retiring that day like two people
were like i'm gonna go tell my boss to
off i'm out of here i said maybe you're
gonna want to give it the 30 days before
you do that well let's talk about this
protect your money and pile up as much
as 794
profits during china's deliberate
economic attack on america
hey does that sound like a curiosity
inducing story or a sensational story
right secondly he says they are
incessantly focused on making sure their
claims are legit
this is also simply false and again i'm
not taking the low-hanging fruit of
stefan georgie's you know memory healer
from several years ago
i could do that all day but let me take
the top players in your industry
people like newmarket health who got
sued by the federal trade commission
for lying about diabetes and again if
anyone wants to defend this
and say that no the big players in our
industry are super honest
no our industry isn't especially bad
please come on
and imagine for a second that some
mainstream advertisers did this
they never would this is uniquely a
direct response copywriting problem
and the sooner people in the industry
address it the sooner you guys can move
on
to better practices but i'll get into
why i don't think that's going to happen
in a second
look at what they say do you suffer from
type 2 diabetes
well maybe your doctor has told you to
keep an eye on your blood sugar
this guy says there's a simple at-home
treatment for type 2 diabetes
that has nothing to do with diet or
exercise and involves no
drugs reverse every symptom of diabetes
in 28 days
without changing your diet without
spending a minute in the gym or taking a
single drug
and no i'm not even kidding this is from
one of the top players in your industry
your tv your cell phone even the
computer screen you're watching on
can slowly silently cause type 2
diabetes and then they show a diabetes
rate
and then electronic device huge usage
like that must be causation right that
couldn't just be correlation abandon
your workouts abandon your insulin
just get ir blockers totally insane now
i'm gonna argue that a lot of
what makes stefan wrong here is that he
conflates the difference between
illegal and unethical right there
those are two very different things
there are a lot of things that are legal
to do
that many of us would consider unethical
now unfortunately
some of this industry not all of it
certainly not all of it
but some of this industry thinks that if
you ever try to
start pushing back and saying hey maybe
this is unethical
even if it's legal to do all of a sudden
oh you must hate making money you must
hate making money that's what this guy
says tim i find that a lot of people who
watch
my channel is their con to reconfirm
their beliefs on making money that
everyone is a scam
everyone is greedy everyone is bad no
just you tim
it's almost like they're trying to
convince themselves that making a lot of
money
is evil again no
but some ways of making money is evil
selling
the memory healer is evil it's unethical
even if stephen georgie never
technically got prosecuted for it
even if it was never considered illegal
it is deeply unethical and uh i
i don't know why that's a conversation
no one's willing to have
but because he conflates those two
things uh he
he when he says this they're incessantly
focused on making sure their claims are
legit
what he's actually saying is they're
incessantly focused on making sure their
claims
are legal not that they don't want bs
claims
they want as many bs claims as they can
possibly fit
while staying legal and once again i'm
going to show you proof of this this is
jenny thompson ceo of new market health
which is a branch of agora
here's her idea of legality notice the
equation for what should be said
is anything short of completely illegal
making sure again that our claims are
kind of right up to the line
but not something that can get us shut
down making sure again that our claims
are kind of right up to the line
and i could really do this all day i
could go after sales letter
after sales letter with you but i think
you get the point
the point is is this is a ridiculous
attempt to try to justify the
really terrible things that are going on
in this industry and again
it's not the whole industry but it is a
lot of the big players
he's lying when he says that the big
players are somehow the ethical ones
how do you figure that buddy here's
joseph schrieffer
one of the top guys at agora financial
uh who we talked about earlier
who stefan uh must think is a pinnacle
of ethics
since they're a big player and he says
the big players are all ethical here's
him saying
we're simply trying to find out what the
new rules will be this is right after a
facebook ad crackdown
how that impacts our copy and if we can
still
acquire customers with the watered-down
claims if we can't say you're gonna make
all this money
we can't promise you the moon how who's
gonna buy our products
you'd never see this with a coca-cola ad
you'd never see this in an
apple ad hey can we still acquire
customers
no you'd never say that because they're
not saying they're gonna make you a
hundred
twelve percent of your wealth they're
not appealing to
desperate people in desperate situations
so i wanted to point that out
that difference that he fails to really
highlight he says oh
maybe we do a little bit more claims so
basically we're just it's just a
different medium right
hey some of our products work some of
them don't no
your your industry is unique it's
uniquely predatory
because it preys on people in desperate
situations
it uses ridiculous claims way more over
the top than
any ad you'd ever see on tv this is not
swiffer versus
the memory healer this is not swiffer
versus the diabetes cure of agora
they're not even in the same league
and combine that with the fact that i've
effectively debunked the idea that
just because they're a big player oh
look at the big players they're they're
ethical right
they're the ethical ones sure at the
bottom you may find problems but look at
the people at the top
hey we've looked at the people at the
top go look at agora go look at their
advertising they're the exact example
i'd use as the textbook
for why uh my case with jim was
completely dead on
so anyways let me know what you think
let me know stefan if you want to come
on the show
and uh have this little chat i hope
you're as willing to defend your
industry live as you were
in this piece and um yeah see you guys
next time and don't forget to smash like
and subscribe thank
[Music]
when you burn through your plastic
stacks
[Music]
a mouthful of money
[Music]
comes along names